game reviewer game review hello my name
is Caleb Denby and welcome back to game
review in today's episode I wanted to
actually go over in amateur game and see
if we could learn anything from it so
this was a game that was played right
here at the st. Louis chess club and one
of our weekly tournaments and the weekly
nights I mean this is a game between
Caleb Gadsden who has a rating pretty
similar to my own he's making a push for
the master title and vineet a tea party
a talented youngster who is part of our
select chess program and is looking to I
think break into the 1800's 1900s since
and beyond in the near future so that is
to say Vinnie was the underdog in this
match but we'll see how both players
approached this game they started with
d4 Knight f6 c4 g6 night c3 Bishop g7
and after e4 black castles my plays
Bishop e2 and black plays d6 so here we
have a mainline Kings Indian defense and
I actually like this opening choice by
by Vinny here the King's Indian of
course is a very combative opening a
very imbalanced opening and a very
complicated opening and against a higher
rate of player I think that's exactly
what you want to be doing you want to
make things complicated because if you
choose a simpler position the fact is
usually the higher rate of player is
just going to play it better than you
whereas if you go for a super complex
position where neither player knows
exactly what's going on the the chance
that one of you makes a misstep is
there's a little bit more level it gives
both players the opportunity to mess up
and then it gives you the chance to
capitalize on any mistakes if your
opponent happens to slip up before you
with that in mind the game continued
Bishop g5 not quite the mainline now
Vinnie develops his Knight to d7 I mean
the way it plays this move h4 and this
is by no means the main move here it's a
bit of a sideline and black
I think responded rather quickly with
the reflexive h5 this is not my favorite
choice bye-bye black as they say in the
back
where I come from there's more than one
way to skin a cat and there's also more
than one way to deal with this age 4-h
five push a lot of us seem to have this
just natural reflex
in this case we respond to age four with
H five sometimes we respond to a four
with a five it just seems like the thing
to do but in fact this is not the best
way to play here for black/white is kind
of wasting his time by playing this move
h4 and so as always you can counter an
attack on the wings with an attack in
the center and that's what Vinnie should
have done and the move c5 is pretty nice
here already claiming these dark squares
forcing white to make a decision
generally white plays d5 here and you
can imagine a six to follow with b5
coming soon I mean I hear you asking a
home well what about this h5 move was
that a threat at all and the answer is
kind of while h5 is nice trying to open
up this file we do still have a very
nice response to keep the file closed in
the move h6 white really isn't
interested in actually capturing this
night because after night takes and if
you want to take on g6 to open the file
you've really actually opened up blacks
rook and trade it off a very important
Bishop before for your attack
so after h6 this Bishop would likely
retreat and we can manage to keep this
file closed in this manner playing h6
and g5 and this spends less time for
black than the other way around and with
this extra advantage in time his plan on
the Queen side has been further advanced
all of this is to say don't just believe
your opponent's threats always you know
you want to take every opportunity you
can to play quickly to play important
moves whereas if your opponent is
playing moves that are somewhat
irrelevant you can ignore them and
continue with the more important central
ideas instead though we see H 5 from
Vinnie a natural reflexive response f3
from white is pretty nice it controls
the e4 square also might hint at some g4
pushes in the future Knight h7 is
finished choice getting rid of this
annoying Bishop Bishop e3 and now have
any continues with E 5 which is one of
the two main breaks in the center here
keeping in mind how white has actually
played here I would have liked to see
the the other pawn break from Vinnie
actually I like c5 in these positions
where white has neglected to develop
this night and made some inroads on the
kingside when white commits things to
the Kings side I like to play on the
Queen side and in vice versa so with c5
what black is kind of saying is he wants
you to play d5 and then he wants to
expand with with this type of maneuver
here and I think this is the better way
to to approach this position with flack
due to the fact that white has committed
to the Kings side with E 5 black is kind
of telling a different story like a
saying no I still want to expand on the
Kings side despite having you having
committed some some time to this side of
the board and I just don't think that's
that's quite right you want to play
where your opponent is weakest b5 not a
terrible move though white your sponge
with d5 taking the central space and now
rook e8 from vini I do think is a little
bit abnormal it does make some sense to
support this pawn and we'll see why at a
later date but I think there were more
active moves that could have been played
such as move like Knight c5 or even a5
to prepare for Knight c5 instead though
riki 8 this bishop comes to d3 eyeing
this at v square this Knight does come
out to c5 Bishop drops back to c2 now we
see a5 supporting this Knight very
natural white finally develops this
Kings side Knight and black continues
with this plan of f5 and once again I
really don't think this is a this is the
main plan that blacks should be focusing
on here white having committed a lot of
his pieces to controlling this King side
is much better prepared to handle this
f5 push that he normally would be and
because of that weight is actually able
to capture this and after Bishop takes
white goes in for a very forced line
this should take c5 and D takes e5 and
now the general rule of thumb is if
white can capture on at 5 and maintain
control of the e4 square he's doing
quite well and that really rings true in
this case he controls efore and after
Knight
for it's very clear that this bishops
gonna be a little bit locked out of the
game and what's going to have a firm
grip on the position Vinny plays b6
Caleb responds with night for to g3
which is not actually my favorite move
and so if you at home want to take a
guess to see how you think black could
get back into the game this was this was
really his opportunity and it might help
to keep in mind the square that I just
mentioned being extremely relevant to
this position okay hopefully you found
it
the idea for black is to do a very
interesting pawn sacrifice pawn to e4
this was Vinny's one and only
opportunity really to get back into this
game like I said this pawn being stuck
on e5 is really a shame for black it
blocks this bishop and it blocks this
rook and it really makes all of the
black pieces just kind of cramped
they're not doing much they're not as
they're not active they're not attacking
things and so by moving this Knight from
its efore outpost
it gives black this opportunity its push
this pawn to e4 and while it is a
sacrifice for the moment you do pick up
a pawn on b2 and let's say Bishop e5 and
something like Queen d3 well the white
knights are still going to be pretty
active and the white structure is
actually favorable compared to black
structure here on the Queen side this
would have been a lot better way to to
continue the game this rook is very very
active and the black pieces can find
some purpose in life which really that's
all we want instead though vini chooses
Bishop takes c2 and now after Queen
takes c2 this pawn is defended and maybe
black should still play e4 just as a
straight sacrifice this time but it's
much less good if you don't get this
pawn on b2 in return instead black plays
Queen f6 which is just leading to this
very very depressing position where you
have this bishop that's stuck on the
same color as all of these pawns for the
rest of the game rook e8 was black's
choice night to to see three Queen f4
Knight back to e2 takes takes
Knight f6 and now we get just a straight
end game where this Bishop is much much
worse than this night king d3 black
tries b5 it would be a huge mistake to
take this pawn obviously leaving d4
behind and after Knight c3 Vinnie missed
another opportunity to get back into the
game as you've heard me saying this
structure is not good for black in
tandem with this Bishop so what white
what black really wants to do here is
mix up the structure shake things loose
and create some more weaknesses on both
sides so that his pieces can find
activity what he played in the game was
the move b4 and this is the opposite of
what he needed to do this leaves the C
pawn weak and it leaves the white pawns
perfectly connected and you know with
without any issue much better would be
to take this pawn on c4 and after King
takes c4 now all of a sudden White has
things to worry about as well such as
this EEP such as this D pawn as well as
this beep on I have to remove like rook
b8 especially rook before all of a
sudden this King is getting a little bit
too active you know it's it's a little
bit too far advanced feeling a little
bit lonely out here on c5 maybe and
black is actually doing just fine in the
Sun game so another missed opportunity
from vini instead playing b4 we see 94
Bishop e7 this King comes to e2 I'm
going to play through the next moves
rather quickly because it's a lot of
shuffling by both players where neither
of them is willing to over commit or
willing to commit to commit at all
rather to anything important black does
bring this work out to f4 eyeing the one
weakness in the white camp but after
rookie 4 we do see eventually after g3 a
trade of rooks this King comes to e7
Knight g5 rook b8 and this is where the
real shuffling begins b3 from white
keeps things locked down on the Queen
side rook f8 work f1 rook d8 King d3
rook e8
kingi for king of six-night h3 King g7
Knight f2 King f6 King III King rookie
794 King g7 king of - Ricky a tricky one
a lot of shuffling the skin but we'll
see eventually something does break
loose in the ends rookie for okie 7 more
shuffling so that comes back to h3 there
it comes to f7 night f2 rook F 593 Rick
f7 and black has hung upon and this
really spelled death for black of course
black could have maybe held on a bit
longer with a move like King g8 and
eventually which both players got tired
of shuffling which might have never
happened for all we know white is going
to break through with this move g4 this
is the move that he had been avoiding
playing in the hopes that what happened
in the game would happen meaning like
losing a pawn without him having to
commit to anything but after g4 the
position is quite difficult for black
after all h5 will eventually becoming
allowing this king some inroads into the
position keeping an eye on both of these
weaknesses it's going to be a tough game
for for black instead though we saw rook
f7 giving up this pawn and the rest is
kind of history black has to go in for
this rook d6 otherwise moves like Rick
c6 and Erick asics are going to pick up
all of the black Queens side pawns but
this King and pawn endgame is dead lost
which we soon saw a lot here where I
think black resigned with that in mind
thank you so much for joining me for
this episode of game review my name is
Caleb Denby and I'll see you in the next
episode